zwei top positionen in deutschland
werden ja neu besetzt bundestrainer jogi
löw hat sich mit der mannschaft
verabschiedet die bundeskanzlerin wird
dann im september folgen und auch im
bundestag wird viel ausgewechselt viele
abgeordnete treten nicht mehr zur
wiederwahl an
langgediente aber auch solche die nur
für eine legislaturperiode unter der
kuppel gearbeitet haben wie schauen sie
auf dem politikbetrieb was verbindet die
volksvertreter auch wenn man sich
politisch nicht einig ist und wie sieht
ein leben ohne politik aus bye bye
bundestag aussteiger ziehen bilanz ist
unser thema heute in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ja wir haben vier
abgeordnete eingeladen die nicht mehr
wiedergewählt werden wollen
katja suding ist bei uns von der fdp
seit 2017 ist sie im bundestag davor war
sie mitglied der hamburgischen
bürgerschaft fraktionsvorsitzende und
landesvorsitzende für die fdp in hamburg
und von beruf kommunikationsberaterin
und hamburg das ist eine gute brücke
direkt zur fabio de masi von den linken
als stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende war eben auch
spitzenkandidat für die linke in hamburg
seit 2017 auch im bundestag
finanzpolitischer sprecher und obmann
des wirecard untersuchungsausschusses
und da galten sie fraktionsübergreifend
als der experte
einmal selbst volkswirtschaft studiert
und waren ja dann auch davor im
europäischen parlament und unsere beiden
zugeschalteten gäste die sind viel
länger abgeordnete gewesen eckhardt
rehberg begrüße ich herzlich von der cdu
seit 2005 im bundestag vorsitzender des
haushaltsausschusses und seine
politische karriere die begann 1990 im
landtag von mecklenburg-vorpommern und
so vor in der ddr ist jetzt im beruf mit
abitur zum facharbeiter für
datenverarbeitung ausgebildet worden
schönen guten abend herr rebak und diese
lehre mit abitur ist dies in der ddr
gehabt die hat auch christoph matschie
spd eben in der ddr gemacht als
mechaniker dann hat er aber noch
theologie studiert die spd zur wendezeit
am runden tisch vertreten
seit 1990 im bundestag aber es gab
einige jahre zwischenstation in der
thüringer landespolitik unter anderem
bei dort stellvertretender
ministerpräsident herr matschie beginne
ich mal mit ihnen weil sie haben ja
sozusagen die ältesten rechte seit 1990
im bundestag aber eben dann auch mit
unterbrechungen
sie haben ihre in der letzten
sitzungswoche ihren abschied gegeben da
hat auch herr schäuble sich nochmal als
bundestagspräsident sich noch mal
ausdrücklich bei ihnen bedankt da hat
man gemerkt das steckt man nicht so ganz
locker weg also wie schwer fällt ihnen
der abschied
also das ist schon natürlich ein sehr
emotionaler moment ich bin jetzt seit
über 30 jahren hauptamtlich in der
politik und ich habe mich sehr bewusst
entschieden nicht wieder zu kandidieren
aber wenn es dann in die schlusskurve
geht dann wird das schon emotional da
ist ein gutes stück wehmut dabei und auf
der anderen seite freue ich mich
natürlich auch noch mal etwas anderes zu
machen
denn für mich war immer wichtig eine
eigene entscheidung treffen zu können
und das wollte ich auch wenn ich den
schlusspunkt unter die parlamentarische
arbeit setzen also was hat sie denn wenn
nötig gemacht
die erinnerung an die vielen jahre
bundestag
ich bin ja gestartet mit der ersten
gesamtdeutschen bundestagswahl und die
ersten jahre waren natürlich sehr stark
geprägt von dem thema wiedervereinigung
treuhand beispielsweise wo wir gerade
auch die die ostdeutschen abgeordneten
untereinander natürlich versucht haben
uns zu verständigen auch über
parteigrenzen hinweg um diese massiven
ökonomischen umbrüche irgendwie
abzufedern
und das geht dann weiter über meine zeit
als ausschussvorsitzender im
umweltausschuss des bundestages oder
dann als staatssekretär im
forschungsministerium und es gibt viele
stationen auf dem weg die auch sehr
emotional geprägt waren also als die spd
in die regierung kam stand zum beispiel
der erste auslandseinsatz der bundeswehr
im kosovo
ich erinnere mich an die hatten
redeschlachten die wir in der fraktion
dazu hatten
bis die entscheidung für uns klar war
oder ich denke an die situation jetzt in
den letzten jahren die bewältigung der
pandemie die uns auch parteiübergreifend
eine menge abverlangt hat ich glaube da
kann jeder abgeordnete und jeder
abgeordnete auch ein lied davon singen
also diese intensität der arbeit
aufzugeben
das macht mich wehmütig auch
aber die intensität bedeutet natürlich
auch einen hohen einsatz an energie an
lebenszeit und ich bin froh dass ich
jetzt ein bisschen mehr zeit für mich
selbst eher man ist nicht herren und
herren des terminkalenders frau suding
unbedingt das haben sie wahrscheinlich
auch wenn sich jetzt nur eine
legislaturperiode im bundestag war fällt
es ihnen jetzt schwer der abschied oder
sagen sie gut dass die vier jahre vorbei
sind wir weder noch also ich freue mich
auf die zeit danach aber es waren auch
tolle jahre die für ihre bundestag auch
die sieben jahre in der hamburgischen
bürgerschaft
das war schon eine besondere zeit das
ist ich empfinde es auch immer noch so
eine ganz besondere aufgabe dass man als
gewählte abgeordnete er für so viele
menschen entscheidungen treffen kann
darf dass man die verantwortung dafür
bekommt das tun zu dürfen
das ist schon nicht job wie jeder andere
und das habe ich immer als etwas sehr
besonderes empfunden so handelt ganz
ganz tolle zeit aber ich habe ja selbst
bestimmt auch die entscheidung getroffen
jetzt raus zu gehen und bin da völlig im
reinen mit mir und freue mich wirklich
normal ist was hier um was wäre dann
sozusagen der hauptgrund warum sie sagen
mach ich jetzt nicht weiter soll die fdp
in umfragen so gut da besser als die spd
von den matschie ja also ich bin niemand
der schlechten umfrage- werden wir
glauben würde ganz im gegenteil ich habe
ja eigentlich meine gesamte laufbahn
eigentlich die fdp in existenziellen
situationen erlebt als ich damals
reinkam 2011 in hamburg statt wenn ich
gut jahr 2015 wir gerade aus dem
bundestag geflogen da hatten wir die die
landtagswahl zu bestreiten da war es
schwierig 2017 wieder reinzukommen es
waren ja immer extrem situation deswegen
irgendwie liegen wir durchaus das macht
mir auch spaß in solchen situationen zu
wirken
ich bin da ist aber ganz plötzlich
reingekommen hatte nie den lebensplan
berufspolitikerin zu werden und wusste
immer dass es irgendwann zu ende ist
wussten noch nicht genau wann und jetzt
ist einfach der zeitpunkt rehberg sie
sind berufspolitiker erst im landtag
jetzt so lange im bundestag ist das eine
bezeichnung die sie eigentlich gerne
höre eigentlich nicht
weil ich habe vor 51 jahren sie haben
darauf hingewiesen meinen lehrvertrag
unterschrieben beruf mit abitur gemacht
und danach im fernstudium studiert und
auch über ein jahrzehnt gearbeitet und
den dann 1990 selber ins kalte wasser
gesprungen landtag kommunalpolitik
bundestag und diese bezeichnung
berufspolitiker würde ich auf mich auch
nicht gerne anwenden wollen weil für
mich die arbeit in berlin nur die halbe
tätigkeit ist ich bin direkt gewählte
abgeordnete
und deswegen ist der wahlkreis die
arbeit im wahlkreis mit den menschen
hier ebenso wichtig mindestens ebenso
wichtig wie die arbeit im deutschen
bundestag
herr de masi sie haben sich habe es am
eingangs gesagt im namen gemacht durch
den wirecard untersuchungsausschuss
haben sich der eingegraben in all diese
dinge
das ist eine arbeit die ihm im wahlkreis
ja die weit weg ist von dem wahlkreis
von dem was herr rehberg jetzt gesagt
hat ist es für sie gerade war es das
spannende dass man sozusagen hier in der
berliner blase im bundestag sichern so
ein thema so rein arbeiten konnte na ja
ich sag mal so bei mir in hamburg-st
pauli spielt natürlich ich sag jetzt mal
das zahlungsdiensteaufsichtsgesetz eine
untergeordnete rolle
beim wahlkampf das ist ein enormes
privileg dass ich mich um solche themen
kümmern konnte aber ich bin auch in sao
paulo auf der straße angesprochen worden
wir kriegen mit finanzskandale immer
mischt oder mit das ist gut zu wissen
dass wir hier einen abgeordneten nahmen
der sich darum kümmert aber ich bin in
meiner entscheidung auch schon vor dem
skandal schienen gewesen ganz ähnlich
wie katja auch vor längerer zeit habe
ich mich dazu entschieden und ich finde
manchmal soll man gehen wenn es am
schönsten ist aber es ist nicht so dass
man eigentlich dass man ja auch eine
zeit lang braucht bis man eigentlich
weiß wie alles läuft im bundestag und
dann ist nicht eine legislaturperiode
eigentlich ziemlich kurz ja ich war ja
vor schon im europäischen parlament und
wir alle glaube ich sind ja auch
menschen die schon vor ihrer zeit im
parlament politisch
gewirkt haben es ist ja nicht so dass
wir von null auf hundert gegangen sind
und selbstverständlich würde auch vieles
dafür sprechen jetzt die arbeit
fortzusetzen aber ich habe für mich eine
sehr persönliche entscheidung getroffen
ich habe gesagt mein sohn war 5 was ich
in einem parlament eingezogen bin jetzt
wird der 12 und ich will noch ein wenig
zeit mit ihm verbringen
solange er sich für mich noch
einigermaßen interessiert das ist ein
aspekt um der andere war auch dass ich
gesagt habe ich kann auch in einer
anderen rolle weiter öffentlich wirken
und insofern freue ich mich auf die zeit
aber ich bin sehr dankbar dass die
bevölkerung mein chef und ich diesen job
machen dürfen die bevölkerung ist der
chef ok herr beckmann merkmal das war
sie haben ja eben gesagt sie wollen
nicht so als berufspolitiker
wahrgenommen
er sagt er dem maße die bevölkerung ist
der chef ich bin volksvertreter wie sehr
merkt man dass in der arbeit als
abgeordneter oder wie sehr muss man sich
das selber vielleicht auch immer wieder
bewusst machen also ich habe jetzt mal
unsere tragen bank recherchiert also
wahlkreis termin ist das waren für mich
seit 2005 weit über 3.000 termine im
wahlkreis unterschiedlicher art
bürgersprechstunden sozialkunde in
schulen unternehmensbesuche besucher bei
sozialen und karitativen einrichtungen
da willst du natürlich ganz direkt vom
bürger angesprochen oder auch die vielen
bürgeranfragen die laufe der zeit ein
treffen jetzt nicht nur deutschlandweit
sondern besonders aus dem wahlkreis und
als direkt gewählter abgeordneter
ich habe 2013 fast 50 prozent der
stimmen gekriegt 2017 ganz normal knapp
40 prozent
da fühlt man sich einfach dem wahlkreis
verpflichtet und das hat habe die maße
auch schon angedeutet für spezielle
dinge in berlin wird man wohl noch mal
hinterfragt aber dass es dann auch nicht
entscheidend für die reputation und
wahlkreis also wie jetzt die
versicherung steuer für die deutsche
seeschifffahrt
die in die reihe bekomme und insoweit
muss man sich da schon gerade was die
arbeit vor ort betrifft auch die
entsprechende intensität an den tag
legen 22 sitzungswochen sind 22
sitzungswochen in berlin
aber ich sage mal - drei vier wochen
urlaub freizeit der rest ist den
wahlkreis und ist vor allen dingen auch
intensiv und ist eine menge arbeit
versucht uns haben sie ja auch gesagt
man merkt das war das ist ja was was du
nicht nach außen hin gar nicht so
dringend was war so ihre überraschung
was die arbeit betrifft zum beispiel als
sie in den bundestag gekommen sind dass
der bundestag hat mich da gar nicht
überrascht also für mich war auch der
große kt wie wir das eben auch schon
sagte dass der weg überhaupt ins
parlament also damals von null auf
hundert und da habe ich dann gemerkt was
das bedeutet und das waren schon auch
manchmal 80 stunden wochen die man da
durchaus hatte da hat man in der woche
viel zu tun am wochenende geht es weiter
und dann fängt die woche wieder von vorn
haben also das ist schon eine
unglaubliche arbeitsbelastung und das
wird tatsächlich zu draußen nicht so
wahrgenommen und man ist auf einmal eine
öffentliche person das ist
wahrscheinlich auch ein gut nochmal ein
großer unterschied dass alles was man
macht natürlich unter beobachtung steht
ja daran musste ich mich sehr gewöhnt
habe das glaub ich bis heute nicht
wirklich final hinbekommen und freue
mich da auch wieder auf ein stück weit
mehr privatsphäre
okay das glauben sie dass sie das
erreichen wo man sie natürlich kennt in
hamburg wir werden sehen wie sich das
entwickelt ist sicherlich was anderes
wenn man nicht mehr
im mandat ist und dann auch vielleicht
nicht mehr so sehr unter beobachtung ist
herr matschie sie haben von der ehre
gesprochen wie wichtig ist für sie war
und was für gute zeiten aber gab es auch
punkte also gerade diese frage in der
öffentlichkeit stehen natürlich dann
auch in ihren der herausgehobenen arbeit
im thüringer landtag wo sie sagen das
könnte auch eine nummer weniger sein
dass ich sozusagen immer angesprochen
werde und das ist auch eine last ist
na ja klar man entscheidet sich mit so
einem öffentlichen amt auch dafür dass
man sich der öffentlichen kritik stellt
auseinandersetzung und es gibt aber auch
momente klar da sagt manno jetzt könnte
es aber auch mal ein bisschen weniger
sein also zum beispiel meine kinder als
sie noch kleiner waren die waren immer
komplett genervt wenn die mit mir
irgendwo unterwegs waren
und sei es vielleicht am wochenende zum
einkaufen und ich immer wieder von
leuten angesprochen worden bin also
sobald man das haus verlässt gibt es
dann quasi keine privatheit wirklich
mehr
und das muss man sich bewusst machen und
versuchen damit umzugehen für sich
selbst kann man das relativ gut
entscheidend finde ich aber natürlich
hängt auch eine familie mit dran in
meinem fall auch kinder die dann auch
davon betroffen sind und deshalb der
einsatz den man da liefern muss für die
politik da ist schon ziemlich hoch
auch für das umfeld und deshalb war das
für mich immer so also ich kann und
konnte diese arbeit nur machen weil es
für mich eine spannende arbeit war also
für mich ist es auch ein lebensglück
dass ich etwas tun konnte von dem ich
einerseits überzeugt war mit dem ich
andererseits etwas bewegen konnte nicht
nur für mich selbst sondern auch für
eine ganze gesellschaft und das ist
natürlich auch unglaublich spannend wenn
man so eine aufgabe bekommt im leben und
deshalb ich hadere nicht mit den
schwierigkeiten
die eine politische arbeit mit sich
bringt aber ich bin trotzdem auch froh
wenn ich in den nächsten jahren etwas
weniger öffentlichkeit habe und mehr
privat und das glaube ich geht allen so
aber das ansehen des parlaments und auch
der politiker hat man ja eher das gefühl
dass es eher negativer bewertet wird
oder eher gelitten hat in der letzten
zeit als das ist dass man das positive
bewertet hatte der mann sie woran liegt
das
naja oder also ich wollte kurz war an
dem sie dazu fragen und dann damit wir
alle nun ich glaube dass viele menschen
zum beispiel um jetzt mal die krone
krise zu nehmen ein großes verständnis
dafür haben dass da fehler passieren
dass es auch nicht alles immer glatt
oder rund läuft auch viele menschen die
maßnahmen mitgetragen haben aber
natürlich gibt es dann enttäuschungen
stich von masken deals oder wenn nach
fast zwei jahren nach der pandemie die
situation an den schulen unbefriedigend
ist
ich glaube aus meiner politischen sicht
auch dass ein stück weit das alte
aufstiegsversprechen auch gegenüber der
mittelschicht nicht immer und überall
noch eingelöst wurde in den letzten
jahren dass das auch eine rolle spielt
aber wir haben natürlich auch eine ganz
andere brutalere öffentlichkeit
mittlerweile bekommen also wenn ich an
die sozialen medien zum beispiel denke
auch wie schnell wir als politikerinnen
und politiker reagieren müssen und ich
will nicht jammern auf hohem niveau also
wir können selbst entscheiden wir können
selbst entscheiden was wir mitmachen wie
viel wir arbeiten wir machen das aus
intrinsische motivation aber das
geschäft schnelllebiger geworden und
trug man spürt mehr druck also sehr
häufig hat man das gefühl entweder man
gibt jetzt schnell ein statement ab oder
man ist nicht mehr dabei weil auch der
journalismus ich zum beispiel verändert
hat auch der funktioniert über das so
genannte klick bett also schnelle
schlagzeile und ich finde schon dass das
auch etwas mit uns macht und vielleicht
brauchen wir wieder ein stück weit mehr
politiker und politiker die auch sagen
ich
macht da mal nicht mit eine runde und
setzt hier mal aus dafür braucht man
aber auch erfahrung und als nicht zum
beispiel als junger abgeordneter ins
parlament kamen da wollte ich natürlich
immer im getümmel dabei sein
herberg wie geht es ihnen seit 2005 im
bundestag was hat sich da geändert auch
gerade was die sozialen medien betrifft
haben wir haben sie den eindruck sie
müssen da ist der druck ist stärker
geworden sie müssen schneller reagieren
aber es hat sich da geändert sagte frau
wird im basischen richtig beschrieben
wenn ich zb habe stellen nichts
persönliches in die sozialen netzwerke
facebook mache ich hier sehr
zurückhaltend was ich finde man muss da
nicht zwingend immer dabei sein und kann
trotzdem ganz gute politische leben an
der stelle was ich die letzten jahre
verändert hat
das ist mails kann man also sind
konfliktfrei wenn ich die abschickte als
patent die sprache hat sich geändert und
eine große rolle hat aber auch glaube
ich dann gespielt zu jedenfalls meine
wahrnehmung in den letzten vier jahren
im deutschen bundestag insgesamt wird
das klima sprache aber auch benehmen
betrifft das die fdp dazu gekommen ist
das war vorher nach meiner wahrnehmung
anders aber wie gesagt ich habe in den
letzten jahren nicht alles mitgemacht
man muss nicht alles mitmachen und kann
trotzdem politisch eine gute und
erfolgreiche arbeit leisten mann hatte
man sie sind so jemand der wirklich da
sie nun auch haushaltspolitiker sind ein
mann der zahlen der sache da
zusammenhalten muss dass sie so jemand
sind der viel fleißarbeit macht und
weniger den weg in die öffentlichkeit
sucht das ist ein richtiger eindruck na
ja also das komplette da ist man glaube
ich schon auch selbst ein bisschen eitel
also wenn man als politiker etwas bewegt
für sein heimatland immer ein beispiel
wir haben in den letzten jahren sechs
forschungseinrichtungen meine kollegen
sonne und steffen von spd sich gemeinsam
dafür gesorgt dass die nach mecklenburg
vorpommern kommen übrigens mehr als ein
dutzend im letzten jahrzehnt insgesamt
in die neuen bundesländer oder jetzt
gerade in der letzten woche mit einem
auftrag für zwei tanker für die
bundesmarine
da wird man ihren werk standort erhalten
der hätte sonst große schwierigkeiten
bekommen also da ist man glaube ich dann
schon auch selber dabei dass man das
auch in die öffentlichkeit trägt also da
ist glaube ich dann auch ein bisschen
politische und persönliche eitelkeit
dabei es gebe ich unumwunden zu ok also
dinge rebecca die afg angesprochen hat
gesagt dass sich da was geändert hat sie
kennen den bundestag nicht ohne afg habe
sie haben als fdp immer direkt daneben
gesessen was waren da ihre erfahrungen
und gab es da punkte wo sie sagen das
war nicht angelegt und den bundestag
nicht angemessen ja da gab es viele
situationen die den bundestag nicht
angemessen gewesen sind wir saßen oder
wir sitzen ja wenn ich tatsächlich
direkt neben der afg fraktion und
bekommen da auch zwischenrufe mit wie
vielleicht von den anderen fraktionen
nicht ganz so gehört werden könne nicht
was sie ihr glaube ich richter war er
auf der anderen seite des hauses ist gar
nicht so viel mit ihr auch dass die
stenografen und das präsidium bekommt
dann nicht immer alles mit aber da
fallen wirklich bemerkungen und setzte
die aus meiner sicht jedes
stammtischniveau nochmal unterschreiten
und das fällt aber manchmal leicht aber
ich mal schwerer
das zu ignorieren aber da ist bei mir
auch manchmal wirklich auch gut
auskommen muss ich sagen dass das so
etwas in einem deutschen parlament
tatsächlich möglich ist und wie sehr
fühlen sie sich verbunden also sie viel
eher rehberg wollten sie mal sagen also
ich will da katja suding ausdrücklich
unterstützen würde ich mal auf der fdp
seite gerade in den abendstunden
gesessen habe das war schon nicht mehr
nur stammtischniveau
das war schon also deutlich deutlich
darunter
das ging schon mit biss rein in den
final bereich dabei
ich wollte wissen wie sie finde finde er
sagt wenn ich das vielleicht ja
vielleicht ein punkt
ich glaube es ist ja nicht nur die
sprache sondern mit der afg ist
plötzlich eine partei im parlament die
eigentlich dieses parlament mich
wirklich akzeptiert und das politische
system und das ist wirklich neu wir
haben natürlich auch in der
vergangenheit immer auf fraktionen im
parlament gehabt die sich auch
kritischer auseinandersetzen auch mal
lautstark aber neben der veränderung der
sprache die wirklich zum teil drastisch
geworden ist ist es für mich besonders
die haltung die sich mit der afg da
plötzlich im parlament ein platz
verschafft hat und die fdp versucht ja
immer die arbeit dieses parlaments
lächerlich zu machen und die politischen
entscheidungen und sich selbst sozusagen
außerhalb der etablierten politik zu
stellen und das finde ich ist gefährlich
und da müssen wir als andere parteien
auch ich finde schon gemeinsam dagegen
halten
wir verbinden das gibt es weil man eben
abgeordnete ist aber man hat natürlich
gerade linke und fdp auf komplett andere
meinungen zu bestimmten themen und sie
sind natürlich konkurrenten aber wo gibt
es punkte auch in den letzten vier
jahren dem motto wo sie sagen da habe
ich das gefühl ja das ist egal zu
welcher partei wir sind eben gemeinsam
parlamentarier und das zählt also
natürlich ist es unsere aufgabe auch
über politische unterschiede zu streiten
sowie in der bevölkerung sowie in jedem
sportverein wir sollen ja die
unterschiedlichen strömungen die es auch
in der bevölkerung gibt darstellen
aber ich muss sagen gerade ich sage mal
die konkurrenz jetzt zwischen linker und
fdp schon allein aufgrund des
wählermilieus geringer ausgeprägt ich
habe zum beispiel eine fantastische
zusammenarbeit mit meinem kollegen
florian tonka von der fdp wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss gehabt auch wenn
wir natürlich in bestimmten dingen zu
unterschiedlichen politischen
schlussfolgerungen kommen war unsere
problemanalyse doch häufig auch von
gemeinsamkeiten geprägt und natürlich
spielt auch so etwas wie persönliche
chemie eine rolle dass wir uns einfach
gut mögen und verstehen und manchmal ist
es sogar einfacher mit abgeordneten aus
anderen fraktionen auch mal ein privates
gespräch zu führen weil man eben nicht
im politischen wettbewerb steht ich will
das ausdrücklich sagen also ich habe
beim fc bundestag zum beispiel das wird
häufiger auch belächelt und es gibt so
ein paar profile dessen um das ist
vielleicht mal den zuschauern zu
erklären es gibt eine fc bundestag wo
abgeordnete eben gemeinsam fußball
spielen gegen andere mannschaft genau
und das hat natürlich auch eine funktion
die man gar nicht unterschätzen darf
weil man abseits des platzes sich näher
kommt mehr über den anderen auch
jenseits des scheinwerferlichts ja vor
dem scheinwerferlicht da muss man sich
immer ein stück weit behaupten beweisen
den anderen mit argumenten niederringen
aber da kann man mal entspannter
sprechen und für mich um das noch zu
sagen gab es ein schlüsselmoment in
dieser legislaturperiode der auch noch
mal die rolle der afd beschrieben hat
das war als der kollege matthias hauer
von der union am rednerpult kollabiert
ist und noch in dem moment wo er da am
boden lag die spendenanrufe aus der fdp
fraktion kam und ich würde mal sagen
dass für ein
für den rest des parlamentes so etwas
undenkbar ist
und das hat tatsächlich gezeigt das ist
hier einfach schlichtweg auch um ganz
banale dinge geht nämlich so wie wir
unseren eigenen kindern beibringen was
ich sage mal gehört nicht gehört das ist
da einfach häufig nicht mehr gegeben
gibt es für diese momente wo sie sagen
da habe ich gemerkt das sind die anderen
parlamentarier sind eben nicht die
politische konkurrenz sondern das ist
ganz wichtig dass wir hier eben auch ja
uns auch anfreunden können
ja da gab es ganz viele momente also ich
kann das auch nur bestätigen
man hat da durchaus freundschaftliche
verbindungen mit abgeordneten anderer
fraktionen man kommt sich auf den
delegationsreisen ehrmann ist in den
ausschüssen
er verbringt man viel zeit zusammen man
hat auch manchmal gemeinsame initiativen
die man die man voranbringt ich weiß
dass wir mit den grünen zusammen an der
grundgesetzänderung gearbeitet haben da
haben wir der hand in hand
zusammengearbeitet also entstehen
manchmal auch wirklich auch allianzen um
politisch etwas umzusetzen dann muss man
sich ja nicht in jedem punkt zu jedem
politikfeld einig sein aber da gibt es
durchaus
sowohl auf der politischen ebene als
auch auf der auf der menschlichen ebene
viel gemeinsamkeiten und das fand ich
immer unglaublich toll dass das man dass
in einem solchen parlament auch erleben
kann das macht es nirgendwo menschlich
und annehmbar werden sie freundschaften
über erhalten
aber ich werde bestimmt kontakt halten
zu sowohl abgeordnetem eine eigene
fraktion also wichtig dass auch schon
sehr lange kenne aber auch zu
abgeordneten anderer fraktionen da bin
ich mir sicher der matte ist es manchmal
einfacher dann wieder dem adidas auch
schon andeutet befreundet zu sein mit
kollegen aus anderen fraktionen wissen
dass peter struck und volker kauder die
beiden fraktionsvorsitzenden wirklich
befreundet sich sehr angefreundet haben
wie ist es bei ihnen über diese lange
zeit weil mit der partei ist ja auch
nicht immer ganz leicht da haben sie
natürlich recht
und deshalb kommt es glaube ich gar
nicht so sehr auf die partei an bei den
persönlichen kontakten und
freundschaften die in der politischen
arbeit entstehen sondern sehr auf den
einzelnen menschen das für mich
jedenfalls wichtig ich habe sehr gute
persönliche kontakte in andere parteien
über die lange zeit gehabt und das sind
auch freundschaften die bleiben und ich
habe mit manchen aus der eigenen partei
nie einen guten draht gefunden und es
gibt personen den werde ich aus dem weg
gehen was mir wichtig ist dass wir als
parlamentarier das auch wirklich pflegen
denn es gibt so was wie einen
demokratischen grundkonsens
und das bedeutet auch dass man
grundsätzlich in der lage sein muss
zusammenzuarbeiten
das gilt für so schwierige situation wie
die pandemie das gilt aber zum beispiel
auch für die außenpolitik in der ich in
den letzten jahren aktiv war
es gibt ja einen konsens in der
außenpolitik der ist viel breiter als
das jetzige regierungsbündnis und das
muss er auch sein weil auch andere
koalitionen die denkbar sind einen
solchen außenpolitischen konsens weiter
tragen müssen und deshalb glaube ich
dass das durchaus bereichernd ist wenn
man über die parteigrenzen hinweg
persönliche kontakte pflegt und ich will
aber auch noch dazu sagen ich habe sehr
viel in all den jahren gelernt von
denjenigen die andere auffassung waren
als ich mit denen ich mich inhaltlich
auseinandersetzen musste und auch das
ist natürlich eine erfahrung die einem
im laufe der zeit reicher macht auch
nachdenklicher macht ich habe am anfang
als ich ins parlament kamen natürlich
sehr auf meiner eigenen meinung beharrt
und ich weiß inzwischen dass es sich
lohnt auf den anderen zuzuhören wenn man
zu guten ergebnissen kommen
harry weg was würden sie denn anders
machen wenn sie jedoch mit der erfahrung
die sie jetzt gehabt haben und wenn man
auf der anderen seite sieht die der ton
in der gesellschaft wird rauer und das
was herr matschie gerade gesagt hat sich
mal zuzuhören ist ja wird ja eher
weniger und das haben wir gerade auch in
der ganzen pandemie zeit gesehen also
gibt einen punkt wo sie sagen ja da
müssen wir als parlament eigentlich da
müssen wir uns das mal anders machen
das könnte ich angehört
sprich jetzt als haushälter im
haushaltsausschuss das ist eigentlich
immer ein sehr sachorientiert arbeiten
der ausschuss wo man glaube ich die
meiste zeit zusammen sitzt besonders
nachdem war ja wo wir zwei haushalte
verabschieden wir haben dann bei den
haushaltsberatungen mittwoch und
donnerstag teilweise 18 12 stunden
ausschusssitzung da gab es jetzt ein
bruch durch corona wo wir dann auch viel
digital gemacht haben auch in den
arbeitsgruppen
ich hoffe dass mit beginn der neuen
legislaturperiode wie der präsenz
möglich ich sage auch notwendig ist und
ich vielleicht müssen wir ich sage mal
deutlicher machen dass die
plenardebatten ja auch ein stück ja ich
nehme das wort politisch oder sind das
nur leider sieht das wort nehme aber das
ist nicht die ausschussarbeit das ist
auch nicht die normale parlamentarische
arbeit und ich muss mich ja immer darauf
einstellen
ich habe zwar 92 13 hatten eine
koalition mit der fdp
dann danach
zwei mal mit der spd wo ich haushalt aus
halter war und bei uns ist es gang und
gäbe wenn andere fraktionen fdp und
grüne auf unsere anträge mit drauf
wollen dass wir sie auch nicht drauf
nehmen also ich glaube es muss viel mehr
nach außen deutlich werden dass diese
politische arbeit im deutschen bundestag
ziel ist auch mal auch
kameradschaftlicher viel kollegialer ist
als es nach draußen wirken
das will man aber dann in
wahlkampfzeiten ja gerade nicht
unbedingt zeigen dann wird man ja zeigen
hier wir sind anders als die also wählt
uns herr de masi wenn sie inhaltlich
voll in erinnere ich immer gern aber ich
glaube also es ist meine wahrnehmung es
kann jetzt nicht norddeutschen
ostdeutsche wahrnehmung sein dass mir
ganz oft menschen sagen streitet euch
nicht so viel sie zu dass sie eine
lösung liegt also die unterschiedlichen
positionen das merke ich ganz oft finde
ich die beschreibe dann sagen wir dann
die leute sie zu dass es löst also mich
interessiert nicht was der und die erde
die und die denkt der marke wollen sie
dem zustimmen es gibt viel bedürfnis
nach harmonie oder er eigentlich nach
wirklicher politischer
auseinandersetzung gerade auch wenn man
solche im letzten jahr sieht in der
korona zeit gab es ja nur eine heftige
auseinandersetzung wir hatten dann lesen
diese große demo vor dem reichstag wo
demonstranten auf den reichstag treffen
gegangen kommen sind also das war ja
noch mal so ein punkt wo man sagt hier
werden wir als parlamentarier doch auch
angegriffen
also ich glaube dass das problem nicht
ist der streit
ich glaube dass die bevölkerung nicht
streit in der sache ablehnen sondern
wieder streit geführt wird und zwar so
dass man am ende auch nicht nur über
unterschiede sondern gemeinsamkeiten
sprechen kann das ist ja das was ich
meinte also ein großteil der bevölkerung
hat glaube ich die krone maßnahmen
mitgetragen aber es gab kritik und dies
auch legitim
und wenn man so in die sozialen medien
guckt da gab es dann entweder diejenigen
die gesagt haben krone existiert nicht
oder diejenigen die vielleicht aus einer
ganz anderen sozialen position ich sage
jetzt mal
mit einer penthousewohnung im
home-office dann darüber geurteilt haben
wie das jetzt für die kassieren ist die
in einer kleinen banken wohnung und und
ich glaube dass auch häufig die debatten
die wir hier in berlin führen die sind
natürlich wir sind teil einer elite ja
einer politischen elite auch die
journalisten wenn man sich so auf
twitter bewegt das hat oft nichts mit
der lebensrealität auf dem land oder so
zu tun und das sind dinge da müssen wir
glaube ich wieder mehr dafür werben auch
gemeinsame positionen zu formulieren das
heißt nicht die unterschiede zwischen
den parteien erwischen aber auch
innerhalb auch innerhalb meiner eigenen
partei nicht sag ich mal eine bestimmte
blase oder lebensrealität nur bespielen
das ist glaube ich ganz ganz wichtig und
dann ist die frage wie man sich streitet
also ich habe sehr positive resonanz
bekommen genauso mein kollege lorenz
rocker von der fdp die damals noch
daniel baier es von den grünen dass wir
natürlich gemeinsam gearbeitet haben und
dann auch unsere unterschiede
dargestellt haben und das haben die
leute alles etwas positives empfunden
wenn ich eine idee einbringen dürfte die
wird nicht alles lösen weil die nicht
alle leute im internet unterwegs sind
das weiß ich als früher
europaabgeordnete aber ich hätte mir zum
beispiel gewünscht dass unsere arbeit im
untersuchungsausschuss auch wie in den
usa mal vor laufender kamera sichtbar
wird weil dann hätten die leute mal
gesehen dass wir bis vier uhr morgens
sitzen und tatsächlich auch
fraktionsübergreifend versuchen
aufzuklären also mehr öffentlich mehr
transparenz wir müssen auch ein stück
weit stolz sein auf das was wir leisten
wenn wir es leisten und ich denke wir
sollten uns nicht verstecken
frau suding was würden sie sagen was wie
müsste das vieh konnte keine
streitkultur besser werden wie kann man
doch das parlament noch mal sichtbarer
machen und hat darf man das zu wenig
gemacht jetzt gerade auch in der
gründerzeit
es ist ja beides richtig auf der einen
seite erwarten die menschen zu recht
dass in der politik lösung gefunden
werden für die probleme die da sind
auf der anderen seite gibt es ja auch zu
recht die erwartungen an die parteien
dass die unterschiede sichtbar werden
einer demokratie geht es ja darum
über die unterschiede festzustellen
welche der partei vertritt interessen
und wer bekommt am ende meine stimme und
deswegen ist es schon wichtig und in der
kroner krise haben wir gesehen dass es
nicht mehr funktioniert hat das
entscheidung natürlich nicht im
hinterzimmer getroffen wenn also
entscheidung die von 16
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin
getroffen werden ohne dass der bürger
nachvollziehen kann welche argumente
eigentlich zu diesen entscheidungen
geführt haben das ist nicht gut und das
führt auch dazu dass sie nicht
akzeptiert werden und wie wir auch oft
gesehen haben dass sie auch qualitative
so schlecht gewesen sind dass sie nur
wenige stunden halbwertszeit hat also da
ist es wichtig dass wir gerade solche
debatten wieder zurück ins parlament
verlagert in die öffentlichkeit das
transparent gemacht wird welche
unterschiedlichen positionen
herangehensweise und konzepte haben die
parteien wie unterscheiden sie sich auch
um dann in der debatte zu einem
bestmöglichen ergebnis zu kommen das
dann auch tatsächlich demand die
probleme der menschen löst da müssen wir
wieder mehr hinkommen herr matti was
haben sie das für gefühl wo haben sie am
meisten bewirkt mehr in der
landespolitik mehr in der bundespolitik
und wenn sie jetzt wenn jetzt junge
menschen sie fragen würden mensch soll
ich eigentlich soll ich mich politisch
engagieren und vielleicht auch mal ein
landtag oder bundestag gehen was unter
den raten also ich würde jedem der sich
für politik interessiert und selbst
gestalten will dazu raten auch politisch
aktiv zu werden und ich sag mal die die
erste ebene die da in den blick kommt
ist natürlich oft die kommunalpolitik
und ich kann auch sagen in der
kommunalpolitik lernt man natürlich sehr
viel über die lebenswirklichkeit ganz
konkret vor ort wichtige umgesetzt
werden müssen aber natürlich sollen sich
auch junge leute trauen für ein
landesparlament oder für den bundestag
zu kandidieren
und was mir dabei wichtig ist es aber
menschen mit zu geben
ihr müsst euch für eure sache einsetzen
aber ihr müsst auch in der lage sein
gemeinsam mit anderen lösungen zu finden
und das ist etwas was durchaus schwerer
geworden
weil der kompromiss wird nicht geliebt
und weil er war das nicht nur nie
wirklich billig aber war dass wenn sie
an ihren kann die erste sein denken also
1990 wo man sagte jetzt sie müssen diese
diese zwei länder zusammen wachsen war
das sind vom chor hat man sich da mehr
angesichts dieser großen aufgabe mehr
zusammen genommen und zusammengerauft
war das große ganze im blick hatte ja ja
also da war da waren kompromisse glaube
ich auch noch etwas einfacher zu treffen
und sind auch eher akzeptiert worden
damals hatten wir die situation dass
dieser gewaltiger umbruch im osten
deutschlands bei dem so viele menschen
ihren arbeitsplatz verloren haben so
viele unternehmen bankrott gegangen sind
und menschen quasi das gefühl hatten ihn
wird der boden unter den füßen
weggezogen also diese diese spaltung
zwischen ost und west war damals
dramatisch und ich habe kollegen aus den
alten bundesländern
manchmal einfach nur unverständnis oder
staunen über die situation gesehen weil
sie das gar nicht nachvollziehen konnten
was aber heute schwieriger geworden ist
über die sozialen medien dass alle die
auf den sozialen medien unterwegs sind
natürlich erleben dass in der regel ihre
meinung bestätigt worden und es kommt
darauf an wenn du durchhält wenn du bei
deiner meinung bleibt dann bist du der
held wenn du ein kompromiss machst dann
ist das schon nicht mehr in ordnung und
das hat eine debattenkultur erzeugt die
ich sag mal den kompromiss schwieriger
gemacht hat und auch die akzeptanz von
politischen lösung schwieriger gemacht
hat aber eigentlich ist es ja die
kernaufgabe von politik kompromisse zu
verkennen dass der wir lernen eine
gesellschaft hat immer vielfältige
interessen hat immer vielfältige
interessen und die müssen miteinander
vermittelt werden und das ist aufgabe
von uns als politiker also
kompromisssuche ist ein hoher wert finde
ich und das sage ich auch denjenigen die
heute als junger menschen die politik
gehen ja du brauchst
ein herbst das brennt für deine ideen du
brauchst einen kühlen kopf aber du musst
in der lage sein auch kompromisse zu
machen
hellberg was ist eine gute voraussetzung
um politiker zu werden also es gibt ja
auch ganz junge abgeordnete die dann
direkt von dem studium direkt an
kandidieren und ins parlament kommen ist
das sinnvoll
jetzt mag ich mit meinen ich finde mit
67 jahren der älteste in dieser runde
das mag jetzt etwas antiquiert klingen
aber ich habe vor 51 jahren im september
1970 mein lehrvertrag unterschrieben
abitur gemacht
dann studiert eine familie gegründet und
bin dann in den landtag gekommen habe
zehn jahren noch kommunalpolitik gemacht
nach 15 jahren landtag dann 16 jahre
bundestag
also mir hat immer geholfen dass ich ein
umfeld hatte meine motorrad meine biker
truppe meine alten freunde aus meiner
jugendzeit
meine frau hat mir dann gelegentlich
auch den kopf zurecht gerückt und heute
sind es meine beiden söhne die rund 40
sind und meine fünf enkel teilweise und
deswegen ich mache das man jetzt ein
bisschen flapsig hörsaal
im kreißsaal hörsaal plenarsaal und wenn
jemand mit mitte zwanzig ich für mich
sagen dass das jetzt gar nicht sein darf
aber dann 40 jahre im bundestag ich das
halte ich ein bisschen für schwierig ich
glaube erfahrung vielfalt auch der beruf
der lebens biografien tun den deutschen
bundestag gut geht es ihnen damit herr
de masi ist das zum punkt warum sie
jetzt auch sagen ich mache jetzt noch
mal was anders damit ich eben nicht die
nächsten 30 40 jahre im plenarsaal
sitzen auch wobei ich bin da ein
bisschen speziell ich bin mit 17 jahren
von zu hause ausgezogen ich habe
toiletten geputzt auf dem bau gearbeitet
also ich habe eine menge jobs gesehen
war eine unternehmensberatung als er
wirklich gab es verschiedene welten
gesehen man hat ihnen das geholfen in
ihrer parlamentarischen arbeit
na ja es hat mir schon geholfen denke
ich weil es gibt diesen alten satz von
einem früheren österreichischen
bundeskanzler man muss die leute mögen
und ich zum beispiel wenn ich durch die
gänge im bundestag gehe und ich sehe die
reinigungskräfte wenn die aus der
toilette kommen ich weiß was sie für den
job machen und wie sie manchmal nicht
gesehen werden zum beispiel im alltag
und ich finde das ist schon wichtig und
es ist auf jeden fall gut dass man
irgendwann sich auch prüft und sagt habe
ich eigentlich noch eine idee davon wie
andere menschen
neben sich fortbewegen müssen etc aber
wie gesagt jeder fall ist auch
unterschiedlich und ich hätte jetzt auch
noch ein paar jahre dranhängen können
oder so ich weiß auch nicht ob ich
irgendwann mal es mich wieder packt sie
schließen das nicht aus dass sie auch
vielleicht noch mal zurückkehren ich bin
ja kein hellseher ich weiß nicht was das
was das leben bringen jetzt diese dass
sie denken um gottes willen nie mehr
parlamentariern natürlich ich habe
meinen job sehr gemocht und mir ging es
genauso wie wie christoph matschie ich
hatte ein bisschen feuchte augen ja also
ich da meinen letzten tag verbracht hat
weil man natürlich eine menge erinnerung
hat aber ich freue mich auch auf das was
kommt und ich finde den luxus zu haben
der samen nach drei minuten was werden
sie machen das wäre einfach alle noch
mal fragen was wenn sie mal ich werde
jetzt ein buch schreiben an einem film
arbeiten und ich versuche andere
abgeordnete weltweit zu beraten bei der
aufklärung von finanzskandalen und dann
schauen wir mal
also sie bleiben dem thema auf jeden
fall treu frau suding was ist denn für
sie dass der punkt wo sie sagen ja was
oder was europas freuen sie sich wenn
sie jetzt nicht mehr im parlament
ich freue mich auf mehr
selbstbestimmtheit und ich bin ja noch
ein bisschen abgeordnet wie wir alle
die wahl ist erst am 26 oktober bis sich
der deutsche bundestag september
anschuldigung irgendwie sozusagen ist
sich der bundestag konstituiert wird es
oktober sein also ich hab da auch noch
einiges vor ort liegt ja noch einiges an
und ich weiß noch nicht genau was ich
tun wenn ich sage mal meine neue aufgabe
wird mich finden und ich bin da noch
sehr entspannt und was würden sie denn
jemandem raten der ins parlament will
was ist eine gute basis eine ganz
wichtige voraussetzung also hast du
schon gehört haben natürlich eine
gewisse lebenserfahrung gewisse
berufserfahrung ist sinnvoll für mich
war damals extrem wichtig dass ich hatte
ja schon einige busfahrer war schon
zwölf jahre im job dass ich wusste wenn
ich wieder raus gehe wenn ich aus
irgendwelchen gründen nicht
wiedergewählt werde wenn ich selber das
gefühl es passt nicht mehr
dann falle ich nicht ins nichts sondern
ich habe einen beruf den ich
zurückkehren kann und muss da nicht
irgendwie an etwas festhalten was
einfach nicht mehr funktionieren herr
rebak die
als norddeutscher oben in rostock sind
die jetzt im moment sind auch ein guter
vertraute von angela merkel die da oben
sich auch ihren wahlkreis hat bleiben
sie mit ihr verbunden denken sie auch
wenn sich jetzt nicht mehr kanzlerin ist
sie sind nicht mehr im parlament ist es
dann so was worauf man sich freut dass
man vielleicht dann als beide als
ehemalige abgeordnete mal über die alten
zeiten redet nicht los wer sich gut 30
erkennt und eine gewisse verbundenheit
und vertrautheit hat der in mecklenburg
vorpommern haben wir gesagt drei
jahrzehnte politisch aktiv das verbindet
und ich gehe davon aus dass wir uns dann
nach dem oktober oder ein bisschen
später ist kann er seine regierung noch
länger im amt ist dass wir uns dann auch
im alter in aller ruhe über alte zeiten
austauschen können ok und ansonsten
denke ich sie freuen sich auf mehr zeit
mit ihren enkeln oder was ihr haupt
klaren wenn wir jetzt mehr zeit nicht
nur enkel ich hab noch wir haben noch
ein paar motorräder aufzubauen
1933 verband kombi baujahr 1978 wird
mich karitativ seemannsmission
engagieren und alles andere lasse ich in
aller ruhe auf mich zukommen herr matla
was freuen sie sich zuallererst freue
ich mich auf mehr zeit und mehr freiheit
und ich habe mich bewusst auch noch
nicht festgelegt für die nächsten jahre
ich habe so ein paar ideen im kopf ich
würde gerne in internationalen projekten
etwas machen in den nächsten jahren aber
was das genau wird dass es noch offen
da sind wir gespannt ihnen herzlichen
dank herrenberg hat sie dann caccia de
masi und frau suding und dann also bis
oktober beschäftigen neue bundestag
konstituiert sind sie abgeordnete ganz
klar da wir haben sie noch was zu tun
und ein bisschen wahlkampf ja vielleicht
auch machen
vielen dank ihnen allen das war die
phoenix runde morgen gucken wir noch mal
ein bisschen er in die welt der israel
unter anderem auch nach portugal und
kümmern uns um das delta virus oder um
das die delta variante des corona virus
und jetzt gibt es für nix der tag mit
seiner bilder
[Musik]